hello when people say that's the most  disgusting show I've ever seen I go good  I'm glad we're doing it right are we  rolling right now we sure are he just  fell out of the chair  good night everyone I'm gonna take a nap  courageable I love this okay well I  always say to people if you don't like  things about me to talk to Katie and Ed  because they raised me if you do like  things about me talk to Katie and Ed  because they raised me so he's so  unattractive just so you know it's like  such an unattractive man it's my friend  James Morrison and I love him very much  how do you guys deal with your anger I  usually just fetal position it I get  really quiet in just fetal position